le cseries est finalement prêt pour sa
sortie dans grand monde
sept appareils cs300 va s'envoler pour
le célèbre salon aéronautique du bourget
où il fera des démonstrations en vol ce
c est sans la version plus courte
restera au sol pour les visites à bord
le moment émouvant pour abdou et il a
été le tout premier employé de la
scission c'est un peu le père du nouvel
avion bombardier a hésité longtemps
avant de lancer sa production car il
s'agissait d'un immense pari la preuve
le programme a pris deux ans de retard à
cinq milliards et demi de dollars son
développement a coûté 2 milliards de
plus que prévu les commandes
environ 600 dont seulement 240 ferme
beaucoup d'experts ont de grands doutes
sur les chances de succès de ce moyen
courrier de 110 à 150 places sa ceinture
est sommé la science de beurre de lait
pas singer les bagages un créneau où il
n'existe encore aucun appareil ces deux
fameux trou noir dont ou personne n'a
réussi le sens place de boeing et
d'airbus sont abandonnés depuis
longtemps toute façon chacun avait été
vendu à moins de 500 exemplaires sur une
quinzaine d'années
face au cseries airbus et boeing ont
réagi en lançant leur version modernisée
d'appareils éprouvé boeing le 737 max et
airbus le a320neo qui utilisent
d'ailleurs le même moteur pratt &
whitney que le cseries pour une guerre
bus ont fait un pacte
vraiment ils ont fait un pacte pour
essayer de tuer series alors on sait que
que par exemple dans certains cas a320
où la famille 320 se voient à moitié
prix 50 % de rabais pour airbus un peu
surprenant parce que c'est à dire là il
a amorti à peu près plus de la moitié du
prix de cet avion la scène profit pur
pourboire pour qu'ils peuvent se
permettre de couper
nous on ne peut pas moi j'ai toujours
considéré que le cseries était un des
plus grands game boy et la plus grande
incertitude
le cseries c'est comme le lancement du
crj1000
des implications financières bien plus
grande c'est ça passe ou ça casse
pas étonnant que les actionnaires soient
inquiets et ils l'ont dit à la direction
celle ci a été complètement changé et
elle a décidé d'émettre des actions de
la filiale ferroviaire pour financer le
secteur aéronautique qui a cruellement
besoin d'argent
malgré ça le nouveau pdg affiche un bel
optimisme
nous avions performe bien en vol
vraiment bien
la performance est excellente on a le
temps on est capable de montrer aux
compagnies aériennes qu'il ya vraiment
de la valeur avec avec ses avions là il
n'est pas le seul à le croire c'est au
moins cinq à dix ans d'avancé sur ses
concurrents les plus proches
donc ça ça nous assure une amante à un
avantage concurrentiel au niveau
technologique pour le futur c'est
bombardier ya cette espèce de panique je
dirais à la rigueur une fausse panique
dans la mesure où obardi ne va pas si
mal que ça les compagnies aériennes sont
beaucoup plus frais 2 attentiste elles
veulent s'assurer qu'elles vont avoir un
produit qui est en ligne avec leurs
attentes
ce qu'elles vont voir c'est un appareil
de conception entièrement nouvelle d
aile en carbone une carlingue en
aluminium et lithium légers et
résistants les moteurs à pratt & whitney
gtf révolutionnaire il ya 20% mois de la
consommation et c'est quatre fois plus
tranquille il ya deux versions de
l'appareil une de 110 places l'autre 240
au début on pensait le cias en vue de ce
succès maxime en ait beaucoup de
demandes pour la cia soit 100 d'accord
parce que le coût d'impression c'est
vraiment le cseries innove aussi avec un
cockpit intuitif où le pilote à toutes
les données possibles sous les yeux en
tout cas pas intégré vraiment les
nouvelles technologies
et on aussi tous les apprentissages
pendant 25 ans parce que vraiment il
n'ya pas vraiment nouveau nouveau
carpet2 dans la cabine tout est plus
grand l'allée centrale les hublots les
sièges le compartiment bagages tout est
plus spacieux que dans les avions
actuellement sur le marché dans ses
fonctions précédentes le nouveau patron
des avions commerciaux fred commun
achetait des flottes d'appareils pour de
grandes compagnies aériennes il sait que
vendre les cseries est un pari risqué
il ya toujours un risque quand on
développe un nouveau programme mais
c'est un risque calculé en raison de la
technologie des gains d'efficacité qu'il
va permettre aux compagnies aériennes de
réaliser
je crois qu'il sera amplement accepté et
largement utilisé ce soit une réussite
on peut absolument parier sur lucie
series on doit parier sur la cseries
cet avion va changer la dynamique dans
le marché de la même façon que
bombardier avait changé la dynamique
dans le marché des avions régionaux avec
le gic c'est véritablement un produit
qui va changer on a changé la gaine
les essais en vol sont presque terminés
et bombardier affirme que l'appareil
dépasse les attentes à l'embauché mais
on est vraiment fier tout le monde voit
ici et son grand sourire parce que on
est vraiment réussie avec la traduit
direction le bourget est le premier
grand test décisif